john speaking of
you know people being disrespectful i
i'd be remiss if i did not
bring up the ridiculous that
uh slapped you twice in the face from
the wwf
i mean these are the types of things
that are just so disrespectful this is
this is what this is an interview this
was an interview john sausal used to do
a lot of man on the street type of
interviews
i was doing consumer reporting going and
confronting businesses
and saying why are you a crook and i was
always scared i'd be
shot or beaten up or something and
nobody ever did anything because it's
having the cameras kind of like having
mom watching
but finally i i was a high school
wrestler so
the advantage of that i look young now
but when i was in high school
my voice was up here that sucked
um were you one of those guys in high
school that was like 14 yet still had a
mustache or no you grew that you grew
into that later i didn't grow into that
until i was
in my 40s or something i was immature
but i could wrestle
at 95 pounds
[Laughter]
and so i learned wrestling so i was
annoyed at pro wrestling that
a lot of people thought it was real i
thought we should show that it isn't
that we got a wrestler to
to go in the ring and and throw me and
show how they fake
things and talk about him he would use a
razor blade to cut his forehead to bleed
and i wanted to set it up like we
usually do with
the business and say what do you say to
the people who say it's fake
and they vince mcmahon let me go
backstage at madison square garden and i
interviewed
uh an iranian wrestler they were they
the iron sheik
the iron sheep damn the iron sheet shout
out to the iron sheik and the junkyard
dog and sergeant slaughter
hulk hogan oh so macho man randy savage
the ultimate warrior no i don't i never
watched it but go ahead
and i forget what they said but this one
jerk dave schultz
six eight two hundred eighty pounds holy
moly it was very blond hair
was basically the fake hulk hogan a
little bit like that but
he was a real athlete and i think he may
have taken
speed but to get psyched for his
performance he was really wired and i
said
well what do you say about it being fake
you think this is fake
whack he knocks me down one time on the
right and then one time and i stupidly
got up again and he hit me
in the other ear what the hell were you
thinking when that happened
i was thinking holy but i hope the
camera caught this
you said holy i hope the camera
true journalist right there i hope the
camera
is it on your channel or no do you have
the video or no on your channel
it's not on my channel but sadly youtube
it's one of my
most watched videos if you type in john
stossel that comes up
i don't know if you know that well maybe
on you know google has learned to
know you and they think big tech right
now
you you want to see people getting
beaten up it may not come up on somebody
else's feet
so it means you like watching him
getting beat up that's what he
said to you i would give john
a hug so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye